guten tag liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen herzlich willkommen zu dieser
pressekonferenz wieder in ungewöhnlichem
ähnlich vielleicht schon jedenfalls
eingeübt im format
trotzdem gibt es neuigkeiten die ich
gleich noch einmal erläutern werde
zunächst aber wir müssen wir unsere
gäste nämlich die bundesministerin für
ernährung und landwirtschaft von julia
klöckner den präsidenten des deutschen
bauernverbandes herrn joachim rukwied
den stellvertretenden vorsitzenden der
bundesvereinigung der deutschen
ernährungsindustrie ehrendoktor
christian von boetticher den
hauptgeschäftsführer des
handelsverbandes deutschland herrn
stefan genth und den präsidenten des
bundesinstituts für risikobewertung
herrn professor dr andreas hensel
herzlich willkommen schön dass sie bei
uns werden uns gleich ihre beobachtungen
informationen zu den auswirkungen der
chor indes der groner krise auch die
ernährungsindustrie auf die
landwirtschaft und den
lebensmitteleinzelhandel schildern
kurz noch mal wie angekündigt zu den
technischen fragen einige kolleginnen
und kollegen sind im saal wir haben
jetzt zum ersten mal die pool regelung
angewendet für pressekonferenzen bei
denen wir eine besonders hohe nachfrage
erwartet haben
danke schon mal für das verständnis bei
allen die sich auf bild fries auf kamera
puls eingelassen haben
wir haben die möglichkeit eröffnet von
außen fragen zu stellen über eine
technische lösung die wir zum ersten mal
ein üben für die die es nicht erreicht
hat bisher es gibt eine mail an alle
mitglieder der bundespressekonferenz
über den livestream in den sich alle
mitglieder einloggen können gibt es eine
möglichkeit unten in einfeld fragen
einzutippen
und ich sehe das dann hier auf einem
ipad die ersten zwei fragen jedenfalls
sehe ich auch schon und da wird das
jetzt tatsächlich zum ersten mal
machen hoffe ich dass es klappt und
bitte schon mal vorab um verständnis
wenn das nicht klappt die können wir
ihnen ausdrucken angeblich auch danach
es wird registriert aber zu verlöschen
verlässlich gelöscht danach ich kann
jetzt schon sagen weil ich hier sehe die
kommen alle ein mit der absender
kennzeichnung viewer zuschauer also es
ist hilfreich wenn sie fragen stellen
dass sie ihren namen und ihr medium mit
drauf schreiben dann kann man das auch
mit ankündigen so dass vorab von
ministerin beginnt ich denke herr
mädchen sehr geehrte damen und herren
danke für ihr interesse
wir werden heute nach der reihenfolge
seiner der lebensmittel lieferkette auch
gerne berichten denn es gibt zahlreiche
nachfragen wie sicher ist die
nahrungsmittelversorgung in deutschland
ich will damit beginnen um klar zu sagen
dass die landwirtschaft und die
ernährungsbranche dass sie unbedingt zur
kritischen infrastruktur gezählt werden
müssen denn sie ist systemrelevant die
ernährungsbranche angefangen von der
landwirtschaft über die
ernährungsindustrie also die
verarbeitung hin zum handeln natürlich
brauchen wir jetzt gerade im ärzte
pflegekräfte polizei feuerwehr und viele
viele andere helfende wichtige hände
aber eben auch all diejenigen die uns
mit lebensmittel versorgen denn es geht
um die versorgung unserer bevölkerung
das sind die landwirte die lageristen
transporteure die große zahl der
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in der
lebensmittelherstellung und der
lebensmittelverarbeitung die kassierer
und alle beschäftigten im
lebensmittelhandel und deshalb meine ich
ist es so wichtig dass genau diese
branche eben zur sensiblen oder zur wie
man es nennt kritischen infrastruktur
gehört denn dann ist auch die
möglichkeit da dass kinder zum beispiel
von diesen wichtigen
berufsgruppen eben auch in der
notfallbetreuung dann auch einen platz
finden die besondere relevanz des
ernährungs sektors muss auch vor allen
dingen in den blick genommen werden wenn
es um quarantäne oder
betriebsschließungen geht vor ort unter
berücksichtigung der notwendigen oder
des notwendigen gesundheitsschutzes muss
diese infrastruktur das will ich vorab
sagen aufrechterhalten werden denn hier
gehen die rädchen ineinander
es geht um die versorgung unserer
bevölkerung die lebensmittelversorgung
ist gesichert
zur aktuellen lage ich bin mit meinem
ministerium mehrmals wöchentlich mit dem
handel mit der ernährungsindustrie mit
der landwirtschaft in kontakt damit wir
einen überblick
eine nahezu tagesaktuellen überblick
über die lage nicht nur bekommen sondern
auch erhalten
gestern haben wir eine große runde in
einer telefonschalte dazu hatten wir
eingeladen das findet nahezu täglich
statt mit verschiedenen runden auch mit
den zuständigen länderministern mit
parlamentariern haben wir gesprochen
heute abend findet eine absprache auch
mit den europäischen parlamentariern
stadt den zuständigen und es gilt
nämlich um folgendes dass unsere
versorgung in deutschland mit
lebensmittel gesichert ist will klar
sagen die supermärkte bleiben offen
sie bleiben geöffnet alles andere sind
falschmeldung
das mag selbstverständlich klingen aber
was wir erleben und erlebt haben
im internet es gibt menschen die machen
sich einen spaß damit andere menschen in
sorge in panik in angst zu versetzen
das ist nicht witzig das ist unanständig
wenn man so vorgeht und zur
verunsicherung der bevölkerung beiträgt
die supermärkte bleiben geöffnet die
lieferkette ist weitgehend diese ketten
sind intakt wo es in einzelfällen zu
engpässen kommt da ist der handel
beschrieb die frequenz der
warenbelieferung zu erhöhen um der
steigenden auch situativ steigenden
nachfrage gerecht zu werden
warenlieferungen aus dem ausland sie
funktionieren so weit wir das
überblicken können natürlich gibt es
auch an der 1
anderen stelle aufgrund von lkw fahrern
die sich entschieden haben den dienst
nicht anzutreten weil sie sorge haben
mit blick auf ihr eigenes heimatland ob
sie dann in quarantäne kommen ob sie
dann nicht wieder reinkommen in das land
da sind bessere kommunikationswege
sicherlich gefragt aber die verhängten
beschränkungen wenn wir uns das thema
grenz sicherungen anschauen beziehen
sich nicht auf den warenverkehr was ich
für wichtig erachte ist dass wir wenn es
zu langen wartezeiten auch an der grenze
kommt im übrigen auch wenn es um
tiertransporte innerhalb der eu geht es
gibt wirklich situationen wo wir eben wo
wir es nicht vertreten können dass man
stundenlang wartet es gibt auch waren es
gibt vieles was sehr termingerecht
angeliefert werden muss und deshalb ist
es oder wäre es sinnvoll wenn es sonder
spuren gebe auch an den grenzen just für
solche lieferungen damit es schneller
gehen würde
ich will deutlich sagen dank unserer
bauern werden in deutschland
grundnahrungsmittel in ausreichender
menge produziert und auch von der
ernährungsindustrie verarbeitet wir sind
mit heimischen mit vier angebaute
nahrungsmittel und auch produzierten
verarbeiteten nahrungsmitteln und
rohwaren sind wir gut versorgt in
deutschland ich will dass etwas
unterlegen wir haben einen
selbstversorgungsgrad von über 100
prozent zum beispiel bei kartoffeln
da liegen wir bei 148 das heißt über den
eigenen bedarf bei käse bei frischmilch
produkte frisch mit produkten bei
getreide bei schweinefleisch zum
beispiel einer flächendeckenden eine
starke landwirtschaft bei uns in
deutschland im eigenen land das werde
ich hier ganz klar sagen ist und bleibt
wichtig denn wir müssen auch eine
gewisse unabhängigkeit für uns auch
bewahren und deshalb wird glaube ich in
diesen tagen noch mal deutlich dass eben
die flächendeckende landwirtschaft
in unser aller interesse ist im übrigen
thema futterversorgung das sind anfragen
die mein ministerium sehr intensiv auch
erreichen
die futterversorgung der tiere ist
gesichert sodass auch fleisch wurst und
mich ebenfalls weiter verfügbar sind
zudem hat auch der
lebensmittelgroßhandel signalisiert im
fall der fälle supermärkte beliefern zu
können sollte es in einzelfällen zu
engpässen kommen denn dadurch dass
schulen kitas kantinen und einige
restaurants in betrieb einstellen stehen
hier vermehrt auch kapazitäten zur
verfügung
ich möchte gerne auch etwas zu den
sogenannten hamsterkäufen sagen sie sind
nicht nur unnötig sie schaden auch
deshalb mein ganz klarer appell an die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
bewahren sie ruhe und augenmaß kaufen
sie mit bedacht ein jetzt ist auch die
solidarität unter den verbraucherinnen
und verbrauchern gefragt wir kommen gut
durch das bin ich sicher durch diese
gesamtgesellschaftliche situation wenn
wir zusammenstehen als gesellschaft und
vorsorge zu treffen auch als haushalt
das ist wichtig aber bitte mit maß und
mitte
kaufen sie bedarfsgerecht ein es gibt
keinen grund lebensmittel zu horten und
auch damit im übrigen um eines zu
vermeiden dass dann gehortete zu viel
gekaufte lebensmittel dann irgendwann
vom vorratsschrank in die abfalltonne
wandern der massiv mehr kauft als er
braucht handelt nicht nur unsolidarisch
sondern wird davon auch einiges weg
werfen lebensmittel verschwenden
ich verstehe dass wenn bürgerinnen und
bürger halbleere oder halb volle regale
sehen das ist ein sich selbst
verstärkende phänomen auch ein
psychologisches phänomen stichwort
hamsterkäufe und deshalb nochmal
falschmeldung verstärken so etwas der
handel ist bestrebt regale zeitnah
wieder aufzufüllen es ist genug für alle
da und wir arbeiten an pragmatischen
lösungen daher begrüße ich auch die
lockerung der sonntags
arbeit und das sonntagsfahrverbot damit
auch waren in den supermarkt ankommen
und auch über das wochenende aufgefüllt
werden können indem ich montags die
läden aufmachen das jährigen wieder
aufgefüllt sind will sagen auch für
andere bereiche arbeiten wir an
pragmatischen lösungen das wird
sicherlich nachher noch eine rolle
spielen sehr sehr viele landwirte
obstbauern gemüsebauern aber auch
jeglicher art die auf mitarbeiter
angewiesen sind landwirtschaft ist
arbeitsintensiv
die auflösung arbeiter angewiesen sind
haben natürlich sorgen haben natürlich
befürchtungen das ernten nicht
eingebracht werden die zum beispiel die
spargelernte wie bevorsteht oder das
erst gar nicht gepflanzt wird und dass
was nicht gepflanzt worden es kann auch
nicht geahndet werden
und wir wollen dass die lieferkette
nicht unterbrochen wird und das fängt
schon bei der urproduktion an und
deshalb arbeiten die an pragmatischen
lösungen etwa wenn es um das personal im
handel oder um arbeitskräfte in der
landwirtschaft oder den gartenbau geht
wie gesagt verpasste amten kann man
nicht nachholen und was nicht gepflanzt
worden ist kann man nicht ahnten
stichwort saisonarbeitskräfte habe ich
erwähnt
deshalb wollen wir will ich auch mit
meinen ressortkollegen einiges prüfen
wir wissen dass zb durch transitländer
einige oder durch einige länder wie zb
österreich auf saisonarbeitskräfte nicht
zu uns kommen können
wir führen auch telefonate und auch
besprechungen ob so etwas auch per
flugzeug möglich sein kann aber da bin
ich in absprache auch mit meinen
ressortkollegen soviel noch dazu es geht
auch darum zu prüfen welche eventuell
starren regelungen wir lockern müssen
wenn es um zuverdienstgrenzen vielleicht
geht oder wenn es darum geht das jede
helfende hand gebraucht wird es gibt
auch branchen deren arbeitsaufträge
leider jetzt nahezu bei null liegen die
arbeit suchen oder menschen die
die gar keine einnahme haben und deshalb
ist es auch eine überlegung in
unkonventionellen zeiten oder in
schwierigen zeiten muss man auch
kreative lösungen finden dass die
menschen die wollen und auch können ohne
große bürokratische hürden auch in der
landwirtschaft arbeiten können zb durch
regional organisierte jobbörsen lassen
sie mich zum schluss kommen wir alle in
der ernährungsbranche und in der
gesellschaft tragen verantwortung wir
müssen alle zusammen an einem strang
ziehen dann bin ich mir sicher werden
wir das auch gut gemeinsam meistern
können und ich habe die hoffnung dass
will ich hier auch sagen dass die
wertschätzung für unsere landwirtschaft
für unsere heimische landwirtschaft auch
wieder steigt und zunimmt dass das was
so schnell daher gesagt wird das seien
alles subventionsempfänger
ich glaube man isst man mag die wichtig
es ist hier in deutschland eine
landwirtschaft zu haben die unter sehr
hohen qualitätsanforderungen arbeitet
die auch ausgleichzahlungen dafür
bekommt um im wettbewerb bestehen zu
können und ich bin sehr dankbar dass wir
eine hochleistungsfähige
ernährungsindustrie haben eine
ernährungswirtschaft haben und ein
handel der sehr diversifiziert ist in
der fläche eben mit läden an zu finden
ist ich danke allen mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern die gerade auch kontakt mit
vielen anderen menschen haben
aber jeden tag ihren dienst tun damit am
ende unsere bevölkerung auch versorgt
wird denn essen müssen wir alle und
deshalb landwirtschaft nahrungsmittel
produktion und die flächendeckende
verfügbarkeit von lebensmitteln sind für
unser land systemrelevant danke frau
ministerin
dann rückt der präsident des deutschen
bauernverbandes mit ihnen dank meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren die
arbeit auf unseren bauernhöfen läuft
trotz corona krise weiter wie bisher
unsere bauernfamilien engagieren sich
auf dem feld im stall und sich und somit
auch
für das jahr 2020 die lebensgrundlage
unserer mitmenschen
wir haben eine starke heimische
landwirtschaft und das ist gut das ist
ganz besonders wichtig in krisenzeiten
wir sind jetzt was die feldarbeiten
anbelangt mit dem beginnenden frühjahr
schon draußen auf den feldern die
frühjahrsaussaat hat begonnen
wichtig für die ernährung ist
beispielsweise der weizen insbesondere
für brot und mehl herstellung auch hier
laufen jetzt die pflegemaßnahmen an und
was auch eine wichtige botschaft ist
auch in den ställen setzen wir unsere
arbeit fort die futterversorgung ist
gesichert so dass wir sehr
zuversichtlich sind dass es in diesem
jahr im hinblick auf ernten und auf
versorgung jetzt mit wichtigen waren wie
mehl dann am ende eben auch die ganzen
brotwaren daraus entstehen fleischwurst
dass es hier keine engpässe geben wird
eine stärke unserer landwirtschaft in
deutschland ist dass die familien
getragen ist und das können wir jetzt
auch ausspielen
die familie hält zusammen steht zusammen
ja da sohn die tochter die zum teil auch
aus landwirtschaftlichen berufen
nachgehen die springen eben jetzt mit
ein damit rund läuft damit die
versorgungskette nicht unterbrochen wird
und ich glaube 1 wird auch heute an dem
bei der pressekonferenz sehr deutlich
dass wir in der kette denken dass wir
gemeinsam denken und herzliches
dankeschön an sie frau bundesministerin
da sie dies auch koordinierenden wichtig
aus unserer sicht ist dass wir gemeinsam
die herausforderungen angehen
wichtig aus unserer sicht ist auch uns
haben schon angesprochen dass
landwirtschaft liege an der gesamten
bereich zur kritischen infrastruktur
gezählt wird
wir sind ein system relevanter bereich
und wir müssen als solche behandelt
werden dass auch die abläufe die
lieferketten aufrecht erhalten werden
können und das fokussiert sich nicht
ausschließlich darauf die lieferungen
jetzt unsere erzeugter produkte sondern
das beginnt beispielsweise auch beim bei
der beschaffung von betriebsmitteln was
wir auch brauchen in diesen schwierigen
zeiten das sind lockerungen und
flexiblere regelungen für unsere
arbeitskräfte auf den feldern auch in
den ställen und insbesondere brauchen
wir praktikable lösungen für den bereich
der sonderkulturen die pflanzen sind
bestellt ob der salatpflanzen sind
geplant so sind oder brokkoli pflanzen
die müssen jetzt aus ausfällt dazu
brauchen wir unsere saisonarbeitskräfte
die brauchen wir auch nachher für die
pflege der kulturen bis hin zum wein und
obstbau und insbesondere für die ernte
und das heißt für uns dass wir jetzt
praktikable lösungen brauchen damit es
ermöglicht wird das er so kräfte
insbesondere auch aus osteuropäischen
regionen zu uns kommen das ist jetzt ein
grundlegendes thema das auch schnell
gelöst werden muss ich bin mir sicher
dass unsere bauernfamilien unsere
familienbetriebe alles machen werden um
dazu beizutragen dass die versorgung mit
grundnahrungsmitteln auch in den
nächsten wochen und monaten einen
gesamten jahr gesichert ist und ich kann
ihnen zusichern dass wir unseren beitrag
dazu beitragen werden dass unsere
bevölkerung auch in schwierigen zeiten
mit sicheren und hochwertigen heimischen
nahrungsmitteln versorgt
in cannes dankeschön und jetzt ist dann
von boetticher der stellvertretende
vorsitzende der bundesvereinigung der
deutschen ernährungsindustrie
dafür herzlichen dank frau
bundesminister liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren ich will auch mit zwei positiven
aspekten starten nämlich zunächst meinen
dank an die bundesregierung nicht nur
für die exzellente koordinierung die wir
an der ganzen kette der
lebensmittelwirtschaft derzeit erfahren
sondern insbesondere auch dafür dass wir
bereits bei der umsetzung einer
europäischen richtlinie im jahre 2009
als kritische infrastruktur eingestuft
worden sind und das ist nicht
selbstverständlich denn bei der
umsetzung dieser richtlinie damals haben
viele länder der europäischen union ihre
lebensmittelwirtschaft nicht diesen
status zu kommen lassen und das
unterscheidet uns jetzt gerade wenn wir
darüber verhandeln auch örtlich regional
mit den behörden
dieser hinweis darauf dass wir von der
bundesregierung entsprechend eingestuft
worden sind erleichtert im täglichen
umgang an diesen stellen einiges mein
zweiter dank das will ich ganz deutlich
sagen gilt den belegschaften und den
betriebsräten in den food 6000
unternehmen der überwiegend
mittelständischen geprägten
nahrungsmittelindustrie
denn sie können sich vorstellen dass in
den letzten wochen schon ein erheblicher
mehraufwand auf uns zugekommen ist viel
umstellung viele gespräche in den
betrieben zusätzliche natürlich mehr
bezahlte sonderschichten höhere
hygieneanforderungen enger abstimmung
mit den gesundheitsämtern und natürlich
auch eine sehr flexible
arbeitnehmerschaft die den gerade den
bereichen einkauf vertrieb und marketing
inzwischen auch zu teilen in home
arbeitsplätze übergesiedelt sind also
eine vielzahl von veränderungen die wir
in den letzten wochen schon gemeistert
haben und all das hat in der summe dazu
geführt dass wir heute sagen können dass
jetzt die nahrungsmittelkette und die
belieferung auch des einzelhandels mit
nahrungsmittel gewährleistet ist das ist
wirklich keine
beständigkeit gewesen und war ein hoher
aufwand für mich ist wichtig und auch
das haben wir in den letzten tagen
häufig gesprochen dass wir wenn der deko
oder infektion ihren höhepunkt erreicht
hat und davon sind wir offensichtlich
nach expertenmeinung noch ein stück weit
weg dass wir noch ein paar dinge
benötigen um auch dann diese
lebensmittelkette durchgehend aufrecht
erhalten zu können
dazu gehören einige temporäre
flexibilisierung im arbeitsrecht ich
denke an die zehn stunden maximale
arbeitszeit die wir heute haben wir
sicherlich ein bisschen flexibilität
brauchen wir brauchen weitere ausnahmen
in der sonntagsarbeit dass es schon
angesprochen worden
wir brauchen auch mehr flexibilität beim
einsatz von 450 euro kräften auch da
muss man darüber nachdenken ob wir nicht
sozusagen mögliche mehr arbeiten zu
lassen können und denken sie an die
lieferketten wir fahren heute aufgrund
von mangelndem verfahren unternehmern
und fahrern
wenn wir wenn geliefert wird häufig mit
einem fahrrad
das bedeutet für uns auch dass die
lenkzeiten regelungen die wir im
augenblick haben die europäischen
natürlich verankert ist ein stückweit
sicherlich flexibilisiert werden muss
das sind wichtige rahmenbedingungen
damit wir auch dann wenn wir vielleicht
durch ein corona fall oder durch mehrere
verdachtsfälle
anteile der belegschaft verlieren in
zukunft in der lage sind diese hohe
produktions dichte aufrecht zu erhalten
ein weiterer punkt der mir sehr wichtig
ist sind die klare regelung wie wir mit
verdachtsfällen umgehen
ich weiß es ist länder recht und
trotzdem kann ich nur erbitten und
ermahnen wir brauchen dringend ein
einheitliches vorgehen der
gesundheitsämter wir brauchen dabei die
berücksichtigung dessen was ich eben
sagte nämlich dass die kritische
infrastruktur sind und es darf auf gar
keinen fall dazu führen dass werden wir
verdachtsfälle haben oder sogar ein
corona fall haben das dann sofort die
betriebsstätte geschlossen wird wir tun
intern alles dafür dass das auch nicht
notwendig ist in dem wir schichten an
das organisieren in die wir die teams
kleiner machen indem wir auch auf solche
fälle
intern gewappnet sind und dennoch
brauchen wir auch die bereitschaft der
behörden dort mitzuwirken und unsere
dringendste wunsch und bitte die kann
uns keiner behörde erfüllt ist aber
natürlich wir brauchen ein schnelltest
denn nur der schnelltest führt dazu dass
wir nicht teile der belegschaft schon
deswegen verlieren weil sie ein
theoretischer verdachtsfall geworden
sind letzter punkt hygiene und
desinfektionsmittel auch die benötigen
wir wir wissen dass krankenhäuser
natürlich vorrangig zu beliefern sind
aber wir merken auf dem markt dass diese
artikel knapp werden und wir benötigen
sie eben auch dringend um die hohen
standards in unserer
lebensmittelproduktion aufrechterhalten
zu können
aber ich darf sagen in all diesen
angelegenheiten sind wir mit dem
bundesministerium mit unser
bundesministerin aber auch mit den
anderen ministerien in sehr guten
gesprächen und darum gibt es im
augenblick überhaupt keinen grund zu
irgendwelchen hamsterkäufen oder zu
panik in der bevölkerung im gegenteil
das ist jetzt im augenblick besonders
schädlich weil es zusätzlich
schwierigkeiten in die produktion bringt
und zusätzlich den grand der lieferung
sketche unter druck setzt insofern sind
wir auch ein bisschen auf solidarität
auf ein miteinander in der bevölkerung
angewiesen wir in der lieferkette von
der urproduktion bis zum handel
machenden augenblick den schulterschluss
um diese hohen anforderungen weiterhin
aufrecht erhalten zu können und alle
gemeinsam mit guten hochqualifizierten
und gesunden nahrungsmitteln zu
beliefern
vielen dank danke er doch davon wird
jetzt stefan genth der
hauptgeschäftsführer des
handelsverbandes deutschland
vielen dank frau ministerin einen sehr
geehrten damen und herren aus sicht des
handels muss man deutlich sagen solche
eine herausforderung hatten wir
natürlich auch noch nicht und dennoch
muss man deutlich nochmal an der stelle
auch wiederholen dass die versorgung der
bevölkerung mit lebensmitteln auch durch
den handel sichergestellt ist das ist
eine leistung der gesamten
lebensmittelkette von der landwirtschaft
über die produktion bis in den handel
hinein leistungsfähige strukturen
aufrechtzuerhalten
und in der tat auch dafür zu sorgen dass
supermärkte geöffnet sind und dort die
regale auch bestückt sind wenngleich das
kennen wir alle in den letzten tagen ist
immer wieder auch dazu kommen dass
einzelne artikel vergriffen waren aber
frau ministerin dass man angesprochen
hamsterkäufe die wir emotional
menschlich verständlich sehen sind nicht
die lösung
sondern wir sehen also die
lebensmittelversorgung auch morgen noch
gesichert natürlich kann es dazu kommen
dass in einzelnen sortimentsbereichen
artikeln ein supermarkt hat über 10.000
artikel im regal
einzelne produkte nicht greifbar sind
aber im ganzen muss man sagen dass die
lebensmittelversorgung sichergestellt
ist vor allen dingen waren ein großteil
der produkte aus der heimischen
produktion heraus kommen und diese
vielschichtige zusammenarbeit sehr gut
funktioniert eine kurze zwischen
bewerbung der stelle aus sicht des
handels am wochenende als wir
miteinander noch gesprochen ein paar
ministerin gegen das sehr uns sehr stark
um der lebensmittelversorgungskette
mittlerweile haben wir den gesamten
handel eine andere situation mit der
schließung von vielen geschäften mich
von allen geschäften die nicht
lebensmittel verkaufen haben wir eine
der größten herausforderung für den
deutschen einzelhandel der letzten
jahrzehnte wenn man nicht sogar noch
weiter zurück denkt weil natürlich
textilgeschäft der kauf und warenhäuser
parfümerien drogerien sind geöffnet aber
im grunde genommen baumärkte und andere
nicht geöffnet werden dürfen wir haben
hier eine große herausforderung die wir
momentan kaum bewältigen können und auf
der anderen seite haben wir die große
situation dass unsere lebensmittel
märkte in den letzten tagen wesentlich
mehr umsatz gemacht haben als
normalerweise
hier sind wirklich hamsterkäufe
stattgefunden haben kundinnen kunden
sogar mit lkws mit klein lkws und mit
anhängern einkäufe vorgenommen die
eigentlich logisch nicht erforderlich
sind und dazu möchte ich noch ein paar
dinge weiter ausführen
wir sehen deutlich dass in den
logistikketten unserer
handelsunternehmen die warenströme
gesichert sind die zentrallager
funktionieren auch die belieferung
funktioniert so dass es sicher gestellt
ist dass unsere märkte auch geöffnet
haben und in die ministerin auch schon
sagte die fake news am wochenende dass
es zum markt schließung kommt sind
völliger unsinn sondern wir haben die
normalen öffnungszeiten von montag bis
samstags und jetzt gibt es sogar
politisch entschieden die möglichkeit im
bedarfsfall auch sonntag zu öffnen das
sehen wir momentan aber gar nicht als
notwendigkeit an weil die
warenversorgung in der woche
funktioniert wir haben einen klaren
appell an die kundinnen und kunden zu
sehr emotionales zu verstehen ist den
haupt einkauf nicht auf die wochenend
situation auf freitag samstag zu
verlegen sondern in der woche auch
einzukaufen also auch den dienstag und
mittwoch zu nutzen dafür dass wir auch
in der lage sind regale wieder
aufzufüllen und die waren entsprechend
als auch den menschen dann auch anbieten
zu können wir gehen davon aus dass die
öffnungszeiten auch weiterhin so
stattfinden und
aufrecht gehalten werden können aber
wenn alle nach ihrer haushaltsgröße
einkaufen also diese hamsterkäufe
unterbleiben wird es für alle einfacher
übrigen ist das in italien
offensichtlich gar kein problem sondern
da haben wir ein sehr normales
vernünftiges grund verhalten in dieser
doch sehr schlimme situation im
nachbarland
und es funktioniert also deshalb der
appell gleichmäßiger auch auf die woche
zu verteilen
zum abschluss für ein nach 23
bemerkungen die für uns wichtig sind wir
sind dankbar dass auch frau klöckner ihr
haus sich dafür eingesetzt hat genauso
mit den bundesländern die
ernährungswirtschaft in diese kritische
infrastruktur mit einzubeziehen hier
geht es insbesondere um die not
betreuung von kindern von
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeitern weil das
ist die achillesferse die wir auch im
handel haben unsere zentrallager unsere
filialen funktionieren nur haben wir
ausreichend mitarbeiter haben die
hoffentlich nicht von dieser corona
pandemie erfasst sind oder angesteckt
sind und hier im engpässe entstehen
können aber die mitarbeiter werden halt
auch in der fläche gebraucht und von da
ist diese kinder notbetreuung enorm
wichtig die ihr auch in den
bundesländern jetzt eingerichtet ist und
nach anfangsschwierigkeiten auch langsam
ins funktionieren kommt die
arbeitsrechtlichen themen die er von
boetticher angesprochen hat möchte ich
noch mal ausdrücklich unterstützen weil
hier geht es nicht um das problem der
öffnungszeiten gegenüber dem
endverbraucher sondern darum dass wir
die waren auch entsprechend zeitgerecht
in die märkte bekommen wir brauchen wir
sonntags anlieferung ausnahmen vom
fahrverbot an sonntagen von den
lenkzeiten und auch die erleichterung
für sonntagsarbeit wie gesagt nicht für
den verkauf sondern mehr für das
einräumen der ware damit ihm die regale
auch wieder bestückt werden können hier
brauchen wir mehr flexibilität übrigens
gilt dass auch andere restriktionen
beispielsweise des lärmschutzes wenn
lkws dann nachts vor dem supermarkt
fahren in einem wohngebiet wo man
morgens noch einkaufen möchte da haben
wir momentan immer noch probleme im
lärmschutz aber da sind wir sehr dafür
dass man hier ausnahmen fast um diese
einfach praktikablen dinge auf dem weg
zu bekommen
der personenverkehr grenzüberschreitend
und warenverkehr ist noch ein thema wir
sehen in den grenznahen regionen
probleme beispielsweise im saarland und
baden württemberg zu frankreich für die
vielen berufspendler dort auch in
unseren märkten auch in den
zentrallagern arbeiten die wir natürlich
auch dringend brauchen hier gibt es
genauso probleme wie auch eine
berufskraftfahrern die aus polen als
berufspendler beispielsweise nach berlin
und brandenburg kommen
darüber haben wir uns auch mit der
ministerin
ausgetauscht wie man hier noch mehr
unterstützen kann damit eben auch hier
problemlos die dinge laufen die
warenströme auch das wurde angesprochen
obst und gemüse transport und andere
dinge an den grenzen möglicherweise
frankreich spanien italien und den
grenzen stehen hier brauchen wir
natürlich eine überholspur für diese
warenlieferung um die logistik hätten
eben nicht zu unterbrechen um dann auch
die lieferung auch bis in die
supermärkte zu gewährleisten und wenn
man da ansetzt gibt es gute
möglichkeiten auch mit der eu kommission
die ja hier auch schon arbeitet unterm
strich will ich deshalb noch einmal
betonen es gibt maßnahmen die wir
ergreifen können ihn zu verzichten
dienst grenzen ist eben angesprochen
worden
schnelltests aber auch
desinfektionsmittel die verfügbar sein
müssen
da gibt es noch einiges was gelöst
werden muss aber in der grundstruktur
sind wir leistungsfähig und werden die
supermärkte auch im flächendeckend in
deutschland weiterhin zu den gewohnten
öffnungszeiten aufrechterhalten und da
auch für eine ausreichende
warenbelieferung in dieser
zusammenarbeit der lebensmitte
lieferkette sorgen können vielen dank
gut und dann abschließend herr professor
hensel präsident des bundesinstituts für
risikobewertung titel ja sehr geehrte
frau bundesministerin sehr geehrte damen
und herren der zeit leben wir sowohl
weltweit als auch in deutschland eine
sehr dynamische und ernstzunehmende
situation
die wissenschaft ist hier in vielen
bereichen gefragt die deutschen
fachbehörden greifen zur zeit auf ihre
jahrzehntelange gute arbeit auf ihre
jahrzehntelangen guten
arbeitsbedingungen zurück mein statement
bezieht sich insbesondere auf den
bereich der hygiene der
lebensmittelsicherheit einer möglichen
virus übertragung von oberflächen und
bedarfsgegenständen
grundsätzlich gilt erstmal weil der
erkrankung mit corona virus das der
wichtigste übertragungsweg der
sogenannte tröpfcheninfektion ist bei
der die korona sie ihren von infizierten
menschen über tröpfchen in luft
abgegeben und an schließlich
anschließend eingeatmet werden
es gibt derzeit keine fälle bei denen
nachweislich gezeigt wurde dass sich
menschen über den verzehr kontaminierter
lebensmittel oder den kontakt mit
oberflächen mit dem neuen artigen corona
virus infiziert haben auch andere corona
wären die untersucht worden sind
haben keine berichte gezeigt dass es
hier infektionen über lebensmittel oder
über importware oder über kontakt
trockener oberflächen geben kann die
übertragung von oberflächen und
lebensmitteln die kurz vorher mit
größeren mengen viren kontaminiert
worden sind aber durch schmierinfektion
theoretisch denkbar aufgrund der relativ
geringen stabilität von corona viren in
der umwelt wäre dies aber nur in einem
kurzen zeitraum nach der kontamination
wahrscheinlich das sind hier die
fachlichen grundlagen die stabilität von
corona viren in der umwelt hängt von
vielen faktoren ab wie der temperatur
der luft feuchtigkeit und auch der
beschaffenheit der oberfläche sowie vom
speziellen virus stammen und der menge
die inaktivierung ist dabei zeitabhängig
und eine direkte funktion der anfangs
konzentration im allgemeinen sind humane
coronaviren nicht besonders stabile auf
trockenen oberflächen in der regel
erfolgt die inaktivierung in
getrocknetem zustand innerhalb von
stunden bis einigen tagen darauf stellen
auch experimentelle versuchsaufbauten
aktivierung des ask of 2 virus ab dieses
kollegen unsere kollegen den usa vom
ncdc auch schon publiziert haben
beziehungsweise hier in deutschland sind
gibt es studien auch aus bochum und
greifswald für das neuartige kroner
virus saß kopf 2 zeigen erste als
preprint veröffentlichte
laboruntersuchungen aus den usa dass
nach starke kontamination bis zu drei
stunden als soul bis zu vier stunden auf
oberflächen 24 stunden auf karton und
bis zu zwei bis drei tagen auf edelstahl
oder plastik infektes bleiben kann wie
gesagt im experiment und das ist ja erst
mal die grundlage der beurteilung
aufgrund der bisher über ermittelten
übertragungswege und der geringen umwelt
stabilität von bewohner werden ist es
nach derzeitigem wissenstand
unwahrscheinlich das waren wie
lebensmittel oder bedarfsgegenstände und
spielwaren werkzeuge computer kleidung
oder schuhe quelle einer infektion mit
dem neuartigen corona virus sein könnten
dennoch sollten immer die einen
allgemeinen regeln der hygiene wie
regelmäßiges händewaschen mit seife
nicht mit den händen in augen nase
fassen und die hygieneregeln bei der
zubereitung von dem
beachtet werden das virus muss ja erst
einmal in den sein wird gelangen
mit einfachen nacht maßnahmen können
menschen somit helfen sich selbst und
andere
also auch ihre familie vor
infektionskrankheiten dieser art zu
schützen
da die viren etc empfindlich sind kann
das infektionsrisiko auch gegen andere
krank machen der regel durch das
erhitzen von lebensmitteln zusätzlich
weiter verringert werden als sogenannte
behüte wären deren erbgut von einer
fettschicht einer sogenannten lead
schicht umhülltes reagieren corona
weniger empfindlich auf fett lösende
substanzen wie alkohol oder tenside die
als vettel sein seifen oder
geschirrspülmitteln auch enthalten sind
es ist bekannt dass durch diese
substanzen die virusoberfläche
beschädigt und damit das virus in
aktiviert wird das gilt insbesondere
auch dann wenn im geschirrspüler das
geschirr mit 60 grad celsius oder höhere
temperaturen gereinigt oder getrocknet
werden
die bisher bekannten corona beer an sars
oder meeres sind kälte unempfindlich und
können bei minus 20 grad celsius bis zu
zwei jahre im gefrorenen status
infektions bleiben allerdings gibt es
keine konkreten hinweise zu infekten von
saas auf zwei über den verzehr von
lebensmitteln inklusive der
tiefgekühlten lebensmitteln
es ist in der aktuellen situation für
gesunde menschen nicht erforderlich im
alltag desinfektionsmittel anzuwenden
wir haben das schon häufig darauf
hingewiesen welche
desinfektionsmaßnahmen durchzuführen
sind wenn ein infizierter unter
quarantäne im haushalt lebt ist mit dem
zuständigen gesundheitsamt oder den
betreuenden arzt bzw betreuenden ärzten
abzusprechen
nur so können wir jetzt dem virus schwer
machen sich schnell zu verbreiten jede
infektionskette die wir unterbrechen
können sollten wir auch unterbrechen
auf der webseite des bundesinstituts für
risikobewertung finden sie die jeweils
aktiven aktualisierten fragen und
antworten zur sache also noch mal
zusammen aufgrund der übertragungswege
und der geringen umwelt stabilität von
corona werden ist es nach derzeitigem
wissenstand unwahrscheinlich das waren
lebensmittel bedarfsgegenstände und
oberflächen quelle einer infektion mit
salz kopf zwei sind oder sein könnten
vielen dank herr professor insel
dann kommen wir zu den fragen und ich
fahren mal an ich versuche mal zunächst
mal die von außen rein zu nehmen
da sind manche fragen da überschneiden
inhaltlich passe ich das mal zusammen
also es gibt zum beispiel mehrere fragen
zum beispiel von herrn meyer von der dpa
antwort hängt es von der ard gibt es
überlegungen den zugang zu supermärkten
etwa räumlich also nach marktfläche zu
beschränken kann man das verordnen
ab wann könnte solche
zulassungsbeschränkungen geben wie ist
das auch im ausland gibt frage auch an
herrn an profis an herrn insel ob das
sinnvoll wäre aus ihrer sicht ja ich
glaube dass und und auch die frage genau
an
die ministerin ob es möglich ist die
abgabe von warenmengen zu beschränken
wenn die leute einen laster vorfahren
hinsicht überlegen dann fange ich froh
dass sie haben so geschah es sind sie
bereit also die abgabe von
nahrungsmitteln zu beschränken
das ist noch keine überlegung ich schaue
auch den handel an wenn am ende haben
wir sehr unterschiedliche muss man schon
sagen sehr unterschiedliche ja das ist
mal einkaufsverhalten
ich habe mir selbst am wochenende
verschiedene läden angeschaut wir haben
uns ausgetauscht
es gibt städte da gibt es schon eine
beschränkung wo ein einen ein
ladeninhaber oder betreiber das schon
reglementiert was jemand kauft und in
anderen also war es auch wenig im regal
noch gibt und dann gibt es andere leben
da ist von allem noch genügend da da
kommt es auch nicht so zwistigkeiten
also insofern
will ich sagen ich glaube das wäre etwa
die falsche botschaft jetzt zu sagen
nachdem wir verdeutlicht haben es gibt
genügend für alle dass wir jetzt mit
klaren reglementierung entkommen ich
traue unserer bevölkerung zu dass sie
auch mit dem was wir hier sagen umgehen
kann und in dem fall der fälle wo wir
wirklich marken das ist nicht nur ein
bisschen über bedarf es gekauft wird
sondern sogar zwei wagen ich will ein
beispiel nennen was mir einen jemand
erzählt hat ein händler dass zwei wagen
mit toilettenpapier gefüllt worden sind
dass da der marktleiter einschreitet
wenn dann ein regal leer ist das glaube
ich ist verständlich aber das gilt nur
für ganz wenige aber vielleicht ja
natürlich sind wir nur verpflichtet in
haushaltsüblichen mengen ware abzugeben
sie kennen das alle aus der
vergangenheit wenn es so super
sonderangebote haben und einige
zwischenhändler dann versucht haben die
regale von discountern mehr zu kaufen um
dann einen möglichst hohen profit zu
machen die dinge weiter zu verkaufen wir
haben da andere situation heute
deshalb achten wir darauf unser personal
auch aber es gab natürlich auch
grenzsituationen wo dann die
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter im handel
das gar nicht alleine lösen können
appellieren wir natürlich an die
verbraucherinnen verbraucher in
haushalts mengen nur einzukaufen diese
hamster einkäufe ihm zu unterlassen
ich glaube nicht dass wir eine staatlich
vorgegebene verordnete beschränkung
brauchen in der form weil die
warenversorgung sichergestellt und es
regelt sich im grunde genommen bis auf
die extreme situationen die dann auch in
den medien lernen die jeder von uns im
letzten tagen vielleicht vor augen hat
das ist aber nicht der normalfall
und was die zugangsbeschränkung zu
supermärkten anbetrifft ist unseres
erachtens bisher nichts ergangen an
verordnungen das müsst ihr auf
länderebene dann auch passieren und die
frage der notwendigkeit können wir gar
nicht beurteilen ob das sinnvoll
notwendig ist so etwas jetzt
durchzuführen wenn das der fall ist
brauchen wir sicherlich die
unterstützung auch der ordnungsbehörden
das heißt auch der entsprechenden
gesundheitsämter vor ort und der
bundesländer
wenn man so etwas umsetzen das könnte
der handel sicherlich nicht alleine was
wir tun sind natürlich entsprechende
pläne mit unseren mitarbeiterinnen
mitarbeitern das machen die unternehmen
natürlich regelmäßig schulungen
durchzuführen darauf hinzuweisen abstand
zu halten an den kassa
halt auch entsprechend und hoffen sehr
auf das verständnis aber das ist nicht
nur im supermarkt dass hermann becker
auch dass man eben zum zum nächsten
kunden dann entsprechend abstand hält
also die hygiene legen hier eine
richtlinie die wir alle kennen auch
entsprechend einzuhalten und das
funktioniert im großen und ganzen auch
gut weil wie gesagt es gibt gar keine
notwendigkeit jetzt für einen hektischen
supermarkteinkauf in dieser form ja
vielleicht ganz kurz zu den
zugangsbeschränkungen man wenn man sich
einmal in europa umschaut sieht man ja
jede form der ausprägung es gibt also
die läden wo die in italien wo die
carabinieri den zugang regeln bis hin
zur unbeschränkten zugang die frage ist
ist das alles nötig
da gibt es ja zwei antworten das eine
ist erstmal die frage der der
medizinischen notwendigkeit und das
andere natürlich die frage für
denjenigen der einkauft wenn sie jetzt
in so ein supermarkt hineingehen und
dort sind sehr sehr viele leute ist
dafür den weg die jenigen der einkauft
immer die frage was bedeutet das jetzt
für mich und ich denke einfach dass es
wichtig ist auch dass man eben auch sich
klar macht dass man da immer diesen
kontrollverlust den man eigentlich
empfindet wenn man einer großen
gesellschaft ist und kein mensch weiß ob
jemand infiziert ist hier ja zurück
erlangen kann indem man sich auch genau
anschaut gehe ich da jetzt rein wenn da
30 40 oder 100 leute drin sind das ist
die eine geschichte die zweite ist
natürlich wie groß steigert steigert
sich die infektionsgefahr
ich denke das ist erstmal davon abhängig
in welchen gebieten da stattfindet ob
eben viele infizierte in diesen
bereichen in diesen regionen eben gibt
das zweite ist natürlich auch es gelten
die allgemeinen hygieneregeln das heißt
die abstand regelung weil sie müssen ja
erst mal mit dieser tröpfcheninfektion
infiziert werden und das ist natürlich
auch eine direkte funktion der menge der
infizierten die dort sind
beziehungsweise auch wie lange sich im
laden hat aufhalten also moment gibt es
immer mehr keine hinweise auch von
unserer schwester würde im
robert-koch-institut dass wir haben auch
für einstellungen bringen sondern wir
haben ja viele bereiche des öffentlichen
lebens wo menschen ja doch in kontakt
kommen wie wir heute hier auch wo ihm
bisher die notwendigkeit nicht gesehen
wurde
die menschen so stark zu vereinzeln das
überhaupt keinen kontakt miteinander
haben und eben auch das allgemeine
lebensrisiko was man beim einkaufen
natürlich weiterhin hat dass man vom
auto überfahren wird oder sonst etwas
natürlich auch weiterhin besteht danke
dann bevor er in den saal gehen schiebe
ich sozusagen als nachfrage noch nach
von der kollegin julia löhr von der faz
die konkrete frage an die ministerin und
herren genth welche erklärung haben sie
eigentlich vor dem hintergrund dessen
was sie gesagt
konkret dafür dass pasta und
toilettenpapier aus dass pasta und
toilettenpapier ausgeht also jedes land
hat seine spezifischen
kulturspezifischen ortungs eigenheiten
habe ich den eindruck als wenn man die
länder vergleicht wird unterschiedliches
zu hause bewahrt also psychologisch bin
ich überfragt und von der vermutung her
passt da hält sich mit pasta kann man
schnell machen man wird satt das kann es
sein und beim toilettenpapier
da braucht man halt gern iss verbunden
ich weiß erkennt ob es nachschub gebe
sie hast ja es gewartet gegebenenfalls
auch dem verband der papierhersteller
ein ja also wir sind alles im klaren
darüber dass wir kein toilettenpapier
horten müssen weil da teilweise
jahresbedarf verkauft wird paradoxes
klopp gibt keine müssen wahrscheinlich
psychologen fragen was die ernährung
betrifft pasta und länger haltbare
produkte setzt mail wird stark
nachgefragt teilweise in 10 und 20
kilogramm portionen gekauft wo
wahrscheinlich die kundinnen oder kunden
die letzten zehn jahre nicht einmal ein
brot gebacken haben das vielleicht auch
dieses jahr nicht tun aber das ist
wahrscheinlich irrationale verhalten
eine längere beine waren haltung mit
waren zu bevorraten die länger haltbar
sind um sich abzusichern nochmals das
ist eigentlich rational nicht
erforderlich übrigens in frankreich
kommt es zu engpässen beim rotwein
sofern sie sich nicht ausreicht relativ
unterschiedlich ist ja mitbekommen dass
das virus alkohol sensibel ist tauglich
hiergegen rotwein im saal haring und
andere gründe
folglich hätte ganz gerne nachgesagt
noch mal bei den saison arbeitern weil
ich mir das noch nicht richtig
vorstellen kann wie das funktionieren
soll
es geht ja doch noch eine relativ große
anzahl von menschen die man als
arbeitskräfte haben möchte müssen sie
das bei der eu kommission beantragen
eine frage zweitens wie soll
sichergestellt werden dass nicht ein
zusätzliches risiko entsteht vielleicht
können sie uns da noch ein bisschen was
zu sagen und das zweites zu der
europäischen oder deutschen souveränität
die sie bei der lebensmittelversorgung
gesagt haben müsste man das nicht
eigentlich europäisch denken und was
wären eigentlich die güter in denen
deutschland oder die eu tag seien
müssten sie haben jetzt eine genannt wo
wir sind aber gibt es quasi ein ziel
auch für andere produkte
einige der fragestellungen die sich
jetzt häufen
die sind da sind wir in der
problembeschreibung alle sehr groß aber
in der lösung so etwas in der schublade
zu haben glaube ich wäre nicht ehrlich
zu sagen man hat zu allem sofort eine
lösung in der schublade
also es geht jetzt darum wie können wir
saisonarbeitskräfte die dringend
gebraucht werden ich will ihnen kurz mal
sagen wir haben eine bundesweite
anbaufläche für spargel zum beispiel
23.000 hektar und der spargel muss
geerntet werden wir haben einen
pflanzsaison und das was nicht gepflanzt
wird kann auch nicht geahndet werden und
dann ist diese lieferketten unterbrochen
von der wir gesprochen haben
deshalb brauchen wir hier lösungen viele
der saisonarbeitskräfte haben nicht
sorgen nach deutschland zu kommen
sondern sie haben sorge wieder zu hause
zurückkommen zu können ohne dass sie in
quarantäne müssen oder ähnliches das
heißt wir sind auch sehr abhängig von
den rahmenbedingungen unserer
nachbarländer und insofern sind die
laterale absprachen aber auch
informationen wichtig so fern ist es
wichtig dass wir auch über müssen
überlegen was wir bei der 60 tage
regelung vielleicht tun kann ich
thematisiere ist
weil wir gerade in der prüfung uns noch
befinden
und das heißt auch dass wir überlegen
müssen ob vielleicht andere wege wenn
menschen eben kein wenn sie getestet
sind wenn sie selbst nicht als wenn sie
selbst nicht infiziert sind
das ist glaube ich selbstverständlich
dass das vorausgesetzt ist dass wir auch
über andere wege nachdenken ob sie
vielleicht auch mit fliegern hierher
kommen können wenn sie wie ich vorhin
sagte nicht durch ein transit land eben
gelassen werden auch dazu habe ich schon
gespräche geführt aber noch nicht
abschließend der weiterer punkt ist dass
wir noch andere fragestellungen übrigens
in der landwirtschaft haben was ist wenn
ein betriebsleiter erkrankt was ist wenn
ein tierhalter erkrankt also das was für
andere wirtschaftsbereiche gilt gilt
auch für die landwirtschaft was das
thema kurzarbeitergeld anbelangt was
auch kredithilfen anbelangt aber tiere
warten nicht auf die versorgung die
müssen versorgt werden
und deshalb ist das genau der punkt was
wir vorhin angesprochen haben in einem
so sensiblen bereich müssen wir auch vor
ort sehen dass die gesundheitsämter auch
diese sensiblen bereiche sehen
laut unserem viel also friedrich
loeffler institut ist bisher keine
übertragung nachgewiesen von einem
infizierten menschen auf ein tier auf
ein haustier oder nutztiere das was wir
auch intensiv jetzt erforschen und
untersuchen auf der insel riems zum
beispiel also das sind viele viele
fragestellungen und ein letztes noch
dazu auch wenn das vielleicht umstritten
ist aber es gibt zurzeit viele menschen
die hätten gerne arbeit weil sie was
verdienen müssen
und es gibt andere branchen die sind
dringend auf helfende hände angewiesen
und dass wir in solchen zeiten wo wir
zusammenstehen müssen auch über
unkonventionelle oder kreative lösungen
nachdenken müssen also vermittlung
vielleicht auch von arbeitskräften die
wollen und können in eine andere branche
im übrigen auch in supermärkten das
haben wir zum beispiel auch dass zb
personalen der gastronomie jetzt wie ich
hörte sich vermehrt auf bewirbt
in supermärkten zum beispiel und dann
müssen dabei fragen wie sieht es dann
aus mit hinzuverdienstgrenzen und solche
fragen dieses konglomerat dessen bitten
wir uns wir haben fallbeispiele
zusammengetragen
endgültige antworten gibt's man nicht
auf alles weil wir da uns auch
europäische abstimmen müssen aber ihre
letzte frage noch mal stichwort europa
ich bin auch mit der mit dem büro der eu
kommissionspräsident in genau wegen
dieser fragen im gespräch sei es zum
beispiel bei den saison arbeitskräften
ob es passierscheine gibt es für
diejenigen die einen arbeitsvertrag in
der tasche haben zum beispiel diese
fragen müssen wir klären
und was jetzt die relevanz angelangt
welche grundnahrungsmittel ist sind so
etwas vorzugeben
ich glaube da müssen ein bisschen
achtgeben dass wir heute nicht in die
planwirtschaft kommen wir haben eine
arbeitsteilige gesellschaft aber was
wichtig ist und das kann ich jetzt für
deutschland sagen ich hier kann jetzt
nicht für die komplette eu reden aber
das wird auch ein thema im übrigen seien
sicherlich bei uns beim agrarrat der
jetzt abgesagt worden ist aber
wahrscheinlich dann telefonisch oder
video konferenzen werden stattfinden
sich gedanken darüber zu machen wie wir
relativ unabhängig sein können das ist
wichtig vor allen dingen wenn wir uns
noch mal gedanken in deutschland machen
was ist uns eine landwirtschaft wert ein
land eine landwirtsfamilie wird nicht
weitermachen wenn ihr erlöst nicht weil
sie das bringt was die familie braucht
zum überleben
und wenn wir höhere standards einfordern
in deutschland speziell standards die
die wettbewerbsfähigkeit auch noch
erschweren von unserem land werden
dann müssen wir uns als gesellschaft
fragen okay was ist uns das wert damit
sie auch in deutschland bleiben und das
ist eine grundsätzliche frage sicherlich
die sich dann auch europaweit die man
sich dann auch stellt aber wir haben in
ihren unterlagen das haben sie
vielleicht gesehen auch noch mal eine
übersicht der produktion der
versorgungsgrad einen letzten punkt
vielleicht noch bei obst und gemüse das
haben sie gesehen liegen wir unter 100
prozent das ist natürlich auch saison
bedingt aber wir sind sicherlich auch an
der zeit zu fragen ob
das ganze jahr über jedes obst haben
müssen
das muss sich jeder selber beantworten
aber natürlich können wir nicht in
deutschland das ganze jahr über
erdbeeren zum beispiel frisch anbieten
aus deutscher produktion zumindest nicht
so wie wir es gewohnt sind
ich hätte noch mal eine frage zu dem
thema über das wir gerade gesprochen
haben
um wieviele saisonarbeitskräfte handelt
es sich denn die wir in deutschland
bräuchten und üblicherweise auch haben
das wäre die eine frage und die andere
frage ist gleich dann frau klöckner
herrnhut und auch er kennt werden jetzt
lebensmittel teurer werden durch
mögliche einschränkungen die die korona
epidemie mit sich bringt zur ersten
frage würde ich gern antwort geben
im letzten jahr haben wir annähernd
300.000 saisonarbeitskräfte in der
deutschen landwirtschaft beschäftigt
diese zahl ist notwendig insbesondere im
sonder kulturbereich der gesamte obst
gemüse aber auch weinbereich darüber
hinaus haben wir aber auch sehr so
arbeitskräfte in den ställen beschäftigt
beim tiere füttern beim melken und das
möchte ich auch noch mal betonen das
heißt die frau bundesminister
angesprochen hat nämlich hier schnell
lösungen auf den weg zu bringen damit
diese so kräfte dann auch zur verfügung
stehen das hat für uns im moment höchste
priorität die pflanzen sind bestellt die
müssen raus
wir selbst haben auch gemüse an war wenn
sie jung pflanzen bekommen haben so ein
zeitfenster von drei vier tagen wenn die
lieferung da ist und dann müssen die
ausfällt und sind die zu großen wachsen
nicht mehr richtig an wir können auch
nicht mehr richtig gepflanzt werden da
ist also ein echter handlungsbedarf von
nöten
was die drei situation anbelangt
zumindest an den rohstoffmärkten sind
die im moment die preise unter druck
der weizenpreis ist unter druck der raps
preis auch im verbindungen im rohölpreis
ist gesunken
das hängt natürlich auch damit zusammen
dass lieferketten unterbrochen sind das
auch wichtige absatzmärkte für uns weil
wir haben 119 prozent oder 117 prozent
selbstversorgung beim schweinefleisch
aber die produkte die wir selbst als
deutsche konsumieren damen
selbstversorgungsgrad von 85% das muss
man auch wissen weil wir vermehrt edle
teile essen und insofern auch in der
jetzt schwierigen situation sind wir bei
bestimmten produkten auf export
angewiesen
der ist auch nicht ganz so möglich und
das belastet momentan die preise
zumindest was die rohwaren anbelangt sie
hatten eine frage ob lebensmittel jetzt
teurer wäre so toll das war endlich auch
gestellt genau einmal
erstens wir nicht sagen dass
lebensmittel in deutschland sehr günstig
sind im schnitt ein deutscher haushalt
gibt unter zehn prozent von seinem
haushaltseinkommen für nahrungsmittel
für lebensmittel aus unter dem aspekt
einfach mal zur einordnung und jetzt
müssen wir zwei aspekte auseinander
halten wir haben in den vergangenen
wochen häufig über preise gesprochen
immerhin wir werden jetzt hier keine
preisverhandlungen machen
sie wissen dass ich keinen hehl draus
mache dass ich der meinung bin dass mit
lebensmitteln keine dumping angebote
gemacht werden sollen nicht als
lockangebote genutzt werden weil dann
wertschätzung auch in den keller geht
und wenn wertschätzung im keller es gibt
auch keine wertschöpfung für die die das
ganze für uns erarbeiten und insofern
unabhängig jetzt davon ist wichtig dass
bei den bauern auch mehr davon ankommt
jetzt speziell hierzu ob aufgrund der
jetzigen situation der korona krise die
lebensmittelpreise steigen dass aufgrund
dieses mechanismus ist das wäre dann der
fall wenn sie sehr sehr knapp werden
würden aber wir haben eben verdeutlicht
dass der nachschub gesichert ist dass
wir das ist situativ also das ist keine
frage ist ob wir genügend versorgung
lebensmittel für alle haben sondern dass
er eine logistische herausforderung rund
80 prozent der lagerhaltung ist auch auf
der autobahn nämlich in lkws
also insofern leichter kann auch
vielleicht habe von boetticher und und
auch herr gentes ergänzen daher genügend
da ist sehe ich jetzt nicht dass die
preise deshalb steigen und ich will ein
sagen sollten sie steigen würde ich mich
freuen wenn bei den landwirten auch
etwas von dieser steigerung erkennen
wenn ich hoffe ich dass verbinden noch
mit einer frage war wer jetzt über
preise sprechen
da kam auch die frage sozusagen im
zusammenhang damit wie sie zur forderung
linken stehen die gehälter für
angestellte im lebensmittelbereich
ja das ist jetzt mal was gehört von den
linken zu der sache also ich ja die
forderungen kann man stellen und ich
glaube man muss das ein bisschen
komplexer und durchdachter bedenken denn
am ende hat es ja auch etwas mit
zuverdienstgrenzen zu tun hat es auch
mit der progression zu tun
das sind auch so vorschläge über die wir
gesprochen haben ich will es jetzt mal
unkonventionell nennen wenn arbeitgeber
einen sogenannten ist weiß noch dass ein
richtiger begriff ist aber corona bonus
ist klar wo der begriff aber sie wissen
was ich meine wenn man irgend einen
bonus zahlen möchte mit oder gutscheine
verteilt oder ähnliches dass man damit
in diese progressionsstufe reinfeld und
nachher dann weniger hat also das ist
ein aspekt aber wahrscheinlich kann die
ernährungsindustrie und handel dazu noch
etwas sagen gerne zum thema preise
vielleicht noch vorweg foreign minister
und werden gerade diese zehn oder zwölf
prozent angesprochen vielleicht da noch
eine ganz kurze bemerkung das ist in
einer volkswirtschaft die so
leistungsfähig ist wie deutschland
natürlich normal ausdruck auf dieser
leistungsfähigkeit dass wir von unseren
privaten einkommen dann weniger geld für
grundnahrungsmittel ausgeben müssen
übrigens die schweizer geben sogar noch
weniger geld aus als die deutschen
obwohl der warenkorb dort sicherlich
qualitativ durchaus
hinter sein wird also ausdruck auch
dieser entwicklung einer wissen wenn es
mal wirklich wohlstandsgesellschaft wir
haben bei lebensmittelpreise in den
letzten zehn jahren eine preissteigerung
von knapp 20 erlebt und wir liegen im
durchschnitt mittlerweile zwei prozent
über dem europäischen durchschnitt
dennoch sind die lebensmittelpreise weil
es einen harten wettbewerb im deutschen
lebensmitteleinzelhandel gibt nach wie
vor für den verbraucher sehr gering und
die aussage dazu ob corona eine
verteuerung erreichen wird kann heute
niemand wirklich ernsthaft und
zuverlässig treffen weil die
preisentwicklung rog weiter dass
ausgeführt auch von anderen faktoren
abhängt und gerade was die
rohstoffpreise anbetrifft nehmen sie nur
ein produkt wie milch 20 prozent der
frischmilch landen wurden die
supermarktregale es wird eben großer
teil weiterverarbeitet noch exportierten
bei fleisch ist es genauso aber insofern
ist es ja wichtig dass man in der
wertschöpfungskette von der
landwirtschaft über die produktion bis
zum handel
ein vernünftiges miteinander hat dort im
qualitativ hochwertige produkte anbietet
und schaut dass auf jeder stufe
natürlich dann auch eine ja nicht nur
leistungsfähigkeit sondern auch eine
überlebensfähigkeit da ist aber nochmals
dadurch jetzt eine preissteigerung
herbeizureden glaube ich wäre nicht
seriös zum thema forderung der linke was
die gehälter anbetrifft gut politik
sollte sich aus der lohnfindung
heraushalten dafür gibt's
tarifvertragsparteien also sozialpartner
wir haben eine sehr hohe wirkung der
tarifverträge im einzelhandel
wenn auch die offizielle tarifbindung
unter 50 prozent liegt bei der richtigen
rechnung juristisch gelten für über drei
viertel der mitarbeiter mitarbeiter im
einzelhandel tarifverträge die als
flächentarifverträge eine große
anwendung hat wir haben heute schon
zuschläge für die arbeit aber 18 uhr 30
und 20 uhr auch in den supermärkten
obwohl sie alle eröffnungs zeit
mittlerweile kennen bis 20 und 21 22 uhr
haben wir zuschläge und wo die
einkaufsgewohnheiten gleich sind heute
ganz normal ist dass man eben auch zu
diesen zeiten einkaufen geht diese
zuschläge sind da was wir als gute
möglichkeit sehen die ministerin hat es
angesprochen wenn man hier einen bonus
für mitarbeiter geben möchte wozu eine
generelle bereitschaft der unternehmen
sicherlich da ist dann wäre das
natürlich signal wenn man hier
steuerfreie zuschläge noch besser
ermöglichen würde
weil ihnen häufig eben daneben solch
eine ein mehr zuschlag den es gibt durch
die sogenannte kalte provision dann
aufgefressen wird und die steuerlast
dann größer ist ein klares signal an der
stelle
wir haben natürlich im einzelhandel
insgesamt drei millionen beschäftigte da
auch andere branchen sind von der korona
entwicklung betroffen und im handel
haben wir diese doppelte situation dass
der gesamte einzelhandel ab morgen keine
umsatz und keine kunden mehr hat aber
kosten und der lebensmitteleinzelhandel
vor großen logistischen
herausforderungen zur zeit steht und
insofern ist es natürlich wichtig dass
wir unsere leute vernünftig bezahlen
denn die leisten momentan sehr sehr viel
und ich denke das tun die unternehmen
auch eine politische forderung zu lasten
dritter ist immer einfach so zu stellen
wir nehmen das aber trotzdem ernst und
ich weiß von den unternehmen dass
natürlich auch gespräche dort
stattfinden und ein aspekt wäre in der
tat das thema steuerfreie zuschläge noch
weiter zu öffnen dort mehr freiraum zu
haben damit wirklich bei den
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeitern das dann
auch ankommt also wird kann ich noch
einen beitrag liefern zum thema preise
die meisten produkte die wir auf dem
deutschen lebensmittelmarkt haben sind
verarbeitete produkte und darum findet
der großteil der preisfindung zwischen
der verarbeitenden industrie und dem
handel statt
und ich kann ihnen sagen zur beruhigung
das sind überwiegend jahres kontakte
dh da wird sich auch wenn es mal
schwierig wird und kneift erstmal kein
produzent hingehen und sagen ich nutze
jetzt irgend eine situation aus um dort
sozusagen höhere preise unterjährig zu
erzielen das ist so gut wie
ausgeschlossen
das heißt erst mal passiert im
preisbereich gar nichts was sich ändern
kann ist wenn sich die rohstoffpreise
auf den weltmärkten ändern
also nehmen wir an wir kriegen jetzt
aufgrund von bestimmten problemen
schlechte ernten oder wir kriegen die
ernte nicht rein
gerade das thema spargel beispielsweise
angesprochen wenn also sozusagen die
rohstoffsituation knapp wird und zwar
nicht nur in deutschland knapp wird
sondern auch auf den weltmärkten knöpfe
und sich darum weltmarktpreise nach oben
entwickeln klar dann ist das eine andere
situation dann werden wir mit dem handel
besprechen müssen dass wir davon
sozusagen mal wieder in der
wertschöpfungskette aufwand und dass wir
auch an den handel und damit auch über
den handel am ende an den endverbraucher
weitergeben können
das sind allerdings langfristige
szenarien kurzfristig aufgrund von
corona kann ich ihnen sagen wird sich da
nichts bewegt danke
sammle ich noch mal fragen die sich um
das thema transport situation ranken von
rabat engel vom luxemburger wort von
herrn wie gold vom blog augen geradeaus
von haben wohl von ap und von moreno von
risiko in frankreich die frage betrifft
alles wie ist die transport situation
gibt es spürbare einschränkungen durch
grenzschließungen gibt es auch so gibt
dann ist absehbar ob transporte ob es
nötig ist für transporte die logistische
amtshilfe der bundeswehr zu erfordern wo
müsste das angefordert werden
und vielleicht auch im zusammenhang
damit es gibt meldungen die lufthansa
wolle für transporte in der luftbrücke
einrichten
wie ist das möglich worauf bezieht sich
das ich werde einige schlagworte hat man
aus nehmen also ob wir die bundeswehr
brauchen
ich werde jetzt mal die kirche im dorf
lassen
das was wir eben erläutert haben ist
dass die lieferkette funktioniert wir
erleben an einigen punkten dass wir bei
den grenzschließungen die zum teil sehr
selbstständig entschieden worden sind
also jetzt nicht europäisch abgesprochen
gewesen sind dass es dort an den grenzen
zu staus kommt und eine lösung könnte
sein ich glaube bevor wir die bundeswehr
einsetzen dass wir warenlieferungen
ermöglichen auf einer überholspur
dadurch kommen zu lassen das wäre eine
möglichkeit dass annegret kramp
karrenbauer
sehr klug und auch sehr frühzeitig
gesagt hat dass die bundeswehr dort wo
sie gebraucht wird hilft das glaube ich
ist gut das ist beruhigend aber ich
meine wir sollten auch das tun was wir
tun könnten wenn neue herausforderungen
sind müssen wir uns neue gedanken machen
aber nicht glaube ich erst das absolute
worst case szenario im blick haben
für mich noch einen punkt mit dem thema
grenzschließungen das ging ja noch mal
über welche probleme beim transport ist
gibt es geht ja ineinander über was ich
gerade gesagt habe da werden wir auch
europäisch und stärker abstimmen und
absprechen müssen
und insofern des werks werden auch
themen im übrigen seinen im kabinett
heute abend wird einen
staatssekretärsausschuss beim chef
bundeskanzleramt tagen und morgen das
kabinett wir sind unter uns
kabinettsmitgliedern weil viele
fragestellungen verschiedene ressorts
betreffen sehr eng miteinander in der
abstimmung und auch sehr bemüht sehr
zeitnah lösungen lösungsvorschläge zu
erhalten
ja ich stelle gerade mal die zusatzfrage
von fahrradhelmen dazu kommt noch mal
kommt ich muss erklären das ist ja nicht
ganz einfach das zu ordnen und zu lesen
nämlich die frage nach exportkontrollen
wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe ging
es darum ob es ähnlich wie beim medizin
gütern auch für die landwirtschaft
ausfuhrbeschränkungen geben könnte das
möglich ist ich sag jetzt mal von meiner
seite und auch herrn rukwied und andere
an
also ist es schwierig für sich
solidarität der anderen zu fordern aber
selber nicht solidarisch zu sein also
ich stelle mir gerade vor dass wir
unseren speiseplan komplett umstellen
sollen also die 148 prozent über dem
selbstversorger also wir liegen bei 148
prozent bei kartoffeln also über den
selbstversorgungsgrad aber liegen
darunter bei gemüse und wenn wir auf der
einen seite gemüse aus dem ausland auch
bekommen aber selbst kartoffeln
exportieren dann ist es für die
abwechslung des eigen
des speiseplans gar nicht so schlecht
also insofern meine ich sind wir noch
sind wir wirklich nicht so weit ich sag
nicht noch so weit weil dann die sorge
bestünde ist das käme mal soweit
ich bin ein fan unseres binnenmarktes
und auch offener grenzen dass wir jetzt
natürlich bedingt andere situative
entscheidungen treffen es ist klar aber
dass dieser austausch nicht ohne not zum
erliegen kommen soll glaube ich ist
sinnvoll denn auch wir sind angewiesen
ich will einfach noch mal sagen
rukwied um bei uns anbauen zu können
sind wir auch auf ich sage jetzt mal
gewisse mittel für die landwirtschaft
als dünger mittel sei es auch
pflanzenschutzmittel sei es futtermittel
auch auf die zulieferung aus anderen
ländern angewiesen also vielleicht mögen
sie ergänzen
also das kann ich nur unterstützen was
sie gesagt haben frau bundesministerin
auch ich selbst bin überzeugter europäer
auch der größte teil meiner
berufskollegen
wir brauchen den innereuropäischen
handel willi von lebensmittel in andere
regionen europas ein großer markt für
uns aber wir importieren
auch lebensmittel bis hin auch
beispielsweise zufälligen ich würde
natürlich eine stärkere eigene werke
erzeugung wünschen aber viele unserer
betriebe bekommen eben auch berge
beispielsweise aus den niederlanden oder
aus dänemark
das muss auch jetzt möglich sein der mit
unsere mastbetriebe dann auch messen
können
also ich würde vielleicht gerne noch
eins anfügen weil ja immer gerne diese
krise zur globalisierungskritik genutzt
wird wir haben ganz viele verarbeitete
ware mit inhalten ingredients anderen
dingen aus der ganzen welt denken wir an
nüsse cacau rosinen ananas orangen
cranberries beim namen ich könnte diese
liste endlos fortsetzen wollen wir jetzt
anfangen zu apostrophieren dass wir
bitte auf all das verzichten sollen das
kann nicht unser ernst und ich sage es
auch vor dem hintergrund dass die
globalisierung gerade auch im
nahrungsmittelbereich natürlich auch
wertvolle arbeitsplätze geschaffen hat
in vielen schwellenländern in vielen
entwicklungsländern wo wir das jetzt
alles wieder rückgängig machen ich
glaube dass
wirklich am ende nicht sinn und zweck
der sache sein wir werden vielleicht auf
einiges jetzt tempo er vielleicht
verzichten müssen das was sie zeigen und
trotzdem sollte das nicht das credo sein
dass wir am besten so zu sagen alles für
uns machen im krempchen sinne ja germany
first oder jura first ich glaube das
darf am ende nicht des credos werden wir
brauchen jetzt auch eine internationale
solidarität und schulterschluss und dazu
gehört auch dass wir weiter offen sind
für produkte und warenaustausch in
europa und auch mit dem rest der welt
ich darf ergänzen darf auch der deutsche
lebensmittel einzelhandel ist nicht nur
global sondern europäisch klar
aufgestellt viele unserer supermärkten
discountern in ganz europa zu finden
und die findet selbstverständlich
natürlich ein austausch von waren stadt
sowohl von ländern aus italien
frankreich spanien nach deutschland als
auch umgekehrt und diesen normalen
freien warenfluss den schätzen unsere
verbraucher den verbraucher auch jeden
tag das zu reglementieren und zu
begrenzen wäre absolut kontraproduktiv
und würde nicht nur den europäischen
gedanken sondern auch den verbraucher
die verbraucherinnen an der stelle
völlig treffen und was eigentlich
insofern nicht sachgerecht werden jetzt
gibt's hier nochmal dazu der zusatz oder
zusatzfragen mit blick auf das stichwort
lufthansa luftbrücke um die meldung die
bundesregierung spreche hier mit der
lufthansa über luftbrücken sonderflüge
für personen und cargo das ist erstmal
eine fragestellung des auswärtigen amtes
und da gibt es gespräche natürlich um
auch deutsche bürgerinnen und bürger
auch ins wieder ins land zu holen aber
da bin ich jetzt das würde ich gerne
meinen kollegen auch überlassen an
außenminister maß aber der laufenden
gespräche und auch das angebot der
lufthansa auch ich habe heute mit dem
lufthansa-chef zum beispiel telefoniert
kapazitäten sind frei auch für für
warentransporte und die frage das hatte
ich vorhin kurz
also caro und die frage ob es möglich
wäre stichwort bei saisonarbeitskräften
die eben nicht über transitländer kommen
können nicht durchgelassen werden ob man
sie per flugzeug
ob man ihnen ermöglichen könnte nach
deutschland zu kommen da gibt es
offenheit aber das müssen wir noch
stärker auch noch abstimmen und klären
gut jetzt an
frau klöckner und herren danach ein
professor hensel können sie den zeitraum
eingrenzen wann das problematisch wird
wenn es nicht genügend saison arbeiter
geben wird denn dann wäre ja die
lebensmittel oder diese diese kette
zumindest unterbrochen wie dramatisch
die situation ist wie schnell kriegt man
100.000 helfer und herr professor hensel
wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden
habe überträgt sich das virus nicht über
waren nicht über lebensmittel und nicht
über bedarfsgegenstände dann kann man
ein brötchen kaufen unbedenklich
sozusagen alles was man gegenseitig in
die hand dann irgendwie man muss das ja
vorher angefragt haben das ist
unbedenklich und dann gehe ich ja
eigentlich sehr einzuschränken wie das
wie das übertragen wird und trotzdem
verbreitet es sich so massiv ist das
also wirklich auszuschließen dass das
über diese produkt übertragung ist und
noch eine fachfrage gibt es eigentlich
dass wir echten überhaupt nicht tiere in
deutschland die das mittlerweile
übertragen darf ich dann da gleich noch
eine frage auch aus dem digitalen raum
anschließen nämlich von frau ihr leben
ski von der neuen berliner redaktions
gesellschaft die am schließt an die
frage macht saison arbeitskräften gibt
es zahlen dazu wie viele arbeitskräfte
braucht die landwirtschaft können sie
dazu zahlen nennen wie viele sie braucht
ja die saison arbeiter einfach alles was
ist war am 2 wir haben ganz konkret kann
ich sagen sind 200 glaube ich 68.000
saisonarbeitskräfte die wir im schnitt
in deutschland haben in etwa dann wird
sich die frage aufgreifen gerade von
frau kunst nur in also noch mal mein
ansinnen ist keine szenarien aufzumachen
die hier eine vorstellung von welt und
kann deshalb will ich deutlich sage
nochmal wir arbeiten an pragmatischen
lösungen und ich gebe meine energie
jetzt nicht dafür her dass ich mir
gedanken damit meine stadt sondern jetzt
die kraft in meinem ministerium und die
energie jetzt zu binden was sein könnte
wann schluss sein könnte mit einer
produktion in deutschland wenn die
arbeitskräfte nicht da wären wir machen
uns eher gedanken und nutzen die energie
die wir eine lösung hinbekommen dass
saisonarbeitskräfte dennoch da sind oder
dass wir aus anderen bereichen ich kann
kurzberichten auch aus einem anderen
bereich der landwirtschaft auch aus
ökologischem landbau die berichten des
zb caterer die jetzt keine aufträge
haben dass deren personal auf den
startschuss wartet man kann es losgehen
dass sie zb in der landwirtschaft
arbeiten können insofern kann ich ihre
frage gar nicht mit einer zeitangabe
beantworten weil ich mir fast sicher bin
dass wir auch lösungen finden werden es
wird zu engpässen sicherlich der an der
ein oder anderen stelle kommen
aber es heißt nicht dass die
landwirtschaft komplett zum erliegen
kommt denn wenn es einschränkungen gibt
und deshalb suchen wir nach lösungen
also soviel dazu und bin ein positiver
mensch und ich habe die land hätte als
sehr anpackend und pragmatisch erlebt
und also was wir normal denn den größten
bedarf an saisonarbeitskräften letzte
zahl die ich hab ihn 286.000 gewesen
sie testen
danke und dieter größte bedarf ist im
prinzip ab zwischen april und ende
oktober zu sehen
dort haben wir pflegebedarf ernte bedarf
und das ist natürlich am ende auch jetzt
im hinblick auf versorgungslage kultur
abhängig dass spargel betrieb der
braucht ab in einigen tagen und dann vor
allen dingen bis zu johannes als april
mai juni rein da braucht er sehr viele
arbeitskräfte des restes rest des jahres
kann wir geringeren stamm auskommen
und insofern ist es auch ein betriebs
spezifisches und kultur spezifisches
thema wir brauchen jetzt für spargel
betriebe für erdbeer betriebe da
brauchen wir jetzt dringend
saisonarbeitskräfte auch größere anzahl
des pflanzen das können sie da brauchen
sie auch welche aber das können sie noch
mit einer geringeren mannschaft machen
auch jetzt beispielsweise im wein- und
obstbau der rebschnitt der
obstbaumschnitt deswegen haben sie in
geringeren wieder auf der bedarf ist
dann sehr hoch bei der ernte und
insofern es ist kultur abhängig
hauptlauf seit april bis ende oktober zu
der frage der der infektiosität auch von
anderen vektoren ich meine alles was wir
im moment berichten findet vor dem
hintergrund der ganz normalen saisonalen
atemwegserkrankungen statt das heißt
also dass das im moment sehen an der
epidemie mit coronaviren findet vor dem
hintergrund zum beispiel mini kuckucken
keuchhusten oder eben auch influenza
virus infektionen statt das heißt wir
können schon mal fest damit rechnen dass
also hier auch übertragungswege gibt
gleichzeitig gibt es alle anderen
infektionserreger die wir auch
üblicherweise und regelmäßig beim robert
koch institut gemeldet bekommen sei es
jetzt campylobacter bakterien
oder viruserkrankungen die über die über
den lebensmittelbereich gehen bis hin
eben auch zu sammeln oder eco die
erkrankungen das passiert immer und
jeden tag weil sie gefragt haben wie
geht es weiter mit den mit der hygiene
weil das ist natürlich immer die frage
wie gehe ich mit dem lebensmittel um das
heißt es im brötchen kaufen dann ist
zurzeit zumindest ihre chance sich also
über über die über die klassischen
infektionserreger zu infizieren
die bleibt genauso bestehen das heißt
also daran können sie eben auch
erkranken wenn sie jetzt hingehen
sie haben so jetzt ist die frage wie
geht das mit dem mit den corona werden
wir haben also und deshalb habe ich das
auch so ganz konkret gesagt also es gibt
im moment bei allem unwissen was man hat
keinen einzigen berichteten fall dass
mit corona wären über einen passiven
rektor über lebensmittel oberflächen
oder bedarfsgegenstände ein mensch
infiziert wurde
warum ist das so sie müssen ja das virus
in kooperieren das heißt also sie werden
es zweifelsfall in die augen in ihre
nase oder eben ihren mund transportieren
können und den können sie vorbeugen
indem sie beispielsweise regelmäßige
handhygiene machen
also das ist also ich die wohl jeder
sich eben auch schützen kann mich in die
augen fassen ist im moment auch so banal
wie das cliq eine von den wichtigen
dingen der normale mensch hat also
zumindest die die wissenschaft im moment
darüber diskutiert wenig chancen sich
über solche vektoren passive vektoren
anzustecken bekennen solche fälle nicht
gewillt sind auch nicht in der
geschichte das ist ja nur nicht die
erste luft getragene atemwegserkrankung
die wir kennen auch über die an bei den
anderen atemwegserkrankungen gibt es
eben solche berichte nicht
nichtsdestotrotz ist natürlich das hatte
ich ja konkret ausgeführt dass auch eine
direkte funktion der viruslast also wenn
sie jetzt direkten kontakt haben mit dem
man ja direkt mit sputen wo also sehr
viele im wald drin sind dann ist die
inaktivierung natürlich immer eine frage
der zeit und deshalb ist es weil sie das
gesagt haben nicht auszuschließen dass
man sich natürlich dran daran ansteckt
weil eben diese inaktivierung auch eine
zeit funktion ist und die mit der
konzentration und der zeit direkt
korreliert ist also ich würde es jetzt
wenn man es darauf anlegt
ich weise wird das gelingen ja also dass
man sich da an steckt und dass es eben
möglich ist das sehen sie auch in den
ganzen vorsichtsmaßnahmen die auch im
medizinischen bereich gemacht haben wo
man sich eben auch persönlich schützen
muss im arbeitsschutz dass solche
passiven oder schmierinfektionen eben
nicht mehr stattfinden aber so für den
alltag eines menschen sich an produkten
anzustellen ist zurzeit zumindest muss
man immer auch sagen bis auf weiteres
gibt es keine erkenntnisse die dazu
führen zu einer alle in aktivierungs
versuche die wir machen sind alles
artifizielle systeme ja wo wir mit
wohnen virus lasten rein gehen und dann
gucken wir welche oberfläche wird das in
aktiviert und es zeigt sich eigentlich
durchgehend durch alle versuche ja das
virus ist in solchen systemen eine
gewisse zeit überlebensfähig aber das
würde eben nicht gespiegelt hallt durch
die epidemiologische situation die wir
im moment gut beschreiben können wir
haben keinen anhaltspunkt dass die man
sich daran an steckt ja bei den tieren
ist es so es gibt ja bei tieren so wie
beim menschen auch noch andere
coronaviren und die frage ob sie das
übertragen können an auf ihre tiere ja
sie geld sicher übertragen können aber
ob die rahn erkranken müssen eine ganz
andere frage die im moment vom friedrich
loeffler institut gelehrt wird also dass
ungeklärt aber die die wahrscheinlich
ist es nicht so weil wenn sie sich das
anschauen welche viren das sind die
werden ja noch einmal stark
differenziert da gibt es ja kronawetter
krone während und gamma coronaviren die
ganz unterschiedliche familien
darstellen so dass also die
infektiosität und auch die produktivität
die induktion von antikörpern button ist
unwahrscheinlich ist also das ist
wahrscheinlich auch schon vom reinen
anschauen eher unwahrscheinlich dass sie
ihre rund oder ihre katze anstecken
können also ich weiß dass das wäre
berichtenswert also wir haben im moment
gibt es corona virus träger nicht bei
tnt gibt es nicht jedenfalls nicht für
dieses
52 wie groß ich möchte kurz ergänzen
weil ich jüngst das gespräch mit herrn
professor mettenleiter den präsidenten
unseres friedrich-loeffler-instituts
genau dazu hatte es ist bisher nicht
nachgewiesen man kann immer nur sagen
was der jetzige stand ist und worauf wir
politiker uns berufen sind die experten
dass es eine übertragung von nutztieren
oder haustier auf den menschen gibt was
wir gerade machen lassen oder was das
institut gerade tut auf der insel riems
unter höchsten sicherheitsvorkehrungen
natürlich ist dass haustiere und
nutztiere auch infiziert werden und dass
man anschauen will wie sich so etwas
verbreitet ob es sich so etwas
verbreitet also die erkenntnisse liegen
noch nicht da sollte es aber so etwas
mal gegeben haben das stimmig herr
professor hensel zu dann wäre das
berichtenswert gewesen und wir hätten
sicherlich davon gewusst also bisher
kann man ein wissenschaftlicher
erkenntnis sagen das ist hier noch nicht
passieren wenn sie den erfolgen dann
sehen sie zum beispiel die
vergleichsweise virus fälle mit saas
oder meeres dort sind die die viren
übertragen wurden durch inzwischen wird
also beide besser zum beispiel war es
also eine schleicht katze und das virus
kam wahrscheinlich von fledermäusen das
wird hier wahrscheinlich nicht viel
anders sein aber dann die entsprechenden
zwischen würde noch nicht gefunden
gut dann geht nicht mal eine frage von
außen rein von frau schirrmacher von der
agrarzeitung erstens gehört der private
landhandel kleinere handelsunternehmen
die landwirte mit pflanzenschutzmitteln
versorgen bzw mühlen mit getreide zur
kritischen infrastruktur
zweitens werden werden
arbeitsrechtlichen vorgaben für
lkw-fahrer ruhezeiten gelockert und
drittens was passiert wenn ein
mitarbeiter im lebensmittellager oder
silo positiv getestet wird
ich möchte die ersten beiden fragen noch
mal sagen ob jetzt lenkzeiten gelockert
werden das haben wir ja vorhin erwähnt
dass das punkte sind die jetzt
notwendigkeiten ausmachen aber es bedarf
der absprachen mit anderen ministerien
denn es gibt ja auch gründe warum es
lenkzeiten gibt und insofern
muss so etwas abgesprochen werden unter
welchen bedingungen ich will jetzt noch
mal was zur kritischen infrastruktur
sagen ja das was auch kohle herr von
boetticher vorhin gesagt hat das findet
ihr national seinen ausdruck darin dass
die unternehmen deren infrastruktur als
kritisch eingestuft sind bestimmte
vorkehrungen also wir müssen ein
bisschen unterscheiden zwischen
kritischer infrastruktur bei welchem
fall grundsätzlich ja
da geht es darum dass bestimmte
vorkehrungen in punkten
gebäude und anlagen sicherheit
insbesondere aber bei aldi sicherheit
einzuhalten sind bis gilt hier
jetzt sind wir aber bei dem aktuellen
corona kontext da wird der begriff der
kritischen infrastruktur anders benutzt
und soll in bezug auf unterstützung
berücksichtigung bei belieferung mit
persönlicher schutzausrüstung rüstung zb
oder kinderbetreuung eine gewisse
sonderstellung ausdrücken so und ein
automatismus dass die einstufung gemäß
eu-recht eine besondere berücksichtigung
im jetzigen kontext dass es das ergibt
das ist dieser automatismus ist nicht
gegeben deshalb sage ich kämpfen wir
dafür und es wird ein thema sein auch im
gespräch jetzt mit den kolleginnen und
kollegen dass die branche eben zur
kritischen infrastruktur auch in diesem
falle quasi eingestuft wird mit allen
konsequenzen dann und jetzt die frage
bei der belieferung wenn man das sich
als gesamtheit eben anschaut ich sage
jetzt meine sichtweise wieder weil das
noch zu klären ist
landwirtschaft ist auch die lieferungen
angewiesen zum beispiel nennt jetzt noch
mal sagt mittel düngemittel
pflanzenschutz mittel und wenn das nicht
gegeben ist ist der anfang der
lieferkette schon quasi gefährdet und
wenn aber die lieferkette als solches
was wir ja auch rollen als kritische
infrastruktur gilt dann muss man es auch
als ganzes sehen das ist meine haltung
und meinung mit der ich in die gespräche
und abstimmung gehe
vielleicht nur als ergänzung dass es
dass es nicht ein automatismus es gibt
es mir klar aber schon von dem von der
logik her
er macht es wenig sinn kritische
infrastruktur in ruhigen und kritischen
zeiten als kritische infrastruktur
auszuloben mit der aufgabe das man sich
bitte auf solche krisen vernünftig
vorbereitet und wenn sie dann da ist
aber zu sagen aber jetzt müssen wir noch
mal neu nachdenken ob du auch wirklich
kritische infrastruktur bist ich weiß
dass die bundesministerin unserer seite
kindersekt und dass wir dass wir andere
vielleicht doch überzeugen das aber
hätte uns macht eine eine andere lösung
als die die wir hier gemeinsam
gesprochen haben schon sozusagen von dem
von dem logischen prozedere wenig sind
ich wollte das nur noch mal in aller
klarheit sagen ja ich hab noch drei
fragen hier im saal und eine nachfrage
noch vom ja wir sollten versuchen schnee
jetzt an sich durchzukommen kurze
präzise fragen aus dem saal noch bitte
vorstand aktiv
ich frage mich sollte es nun doch in
einem mitgliedstaat der eu zu
lieferengpässen kommen es hat ja nicht
jedes land eine starke landwirtschaft
wie deutschland ob man dann schon
überlegt ob es irgendwelche notfall
lösungen schon gibt inwiefern frau glück
dass sie damit ihrem ressort kolleginnen
und kollegen darüber debattieren wäre
deutschland bereits mehr zu exportieren
dem fahrer wie auch die überversorgung
haben genau was würde passieren unserem
verein ja muss man von fall zu fall
entscheiden
was soll nicht antworten das ist so
hypothetisch und so allgemein wir
exportieren heute das was an bedarf da
ist und das was in einer deutsch bei uns
abgefragt wird je mehr hier abgefragt
wird export ist meist auch mit
mehrkosten oder mit mehr logistik
aufwand verbunden
wenn landwirte dass hier mehr absetzen
können ist etwas was anderes also das
kann ich jetzt so pauschal noch mal bier
ich glaube man muss also man sollte sich
auch noch nicht mit problemen befassen
die noch keiner hat weil
man muss vorausdenken das ja was auf uns
zukommen könnte
aber nochmal unsere botschaft ist heute
ist es sind genügend lebensmittel für
alle da und insofern wir haben einen
wahren verkehrt wir tauschen uns da aus
und ja es kommt jetzt nicht so also dass
wir solidarisch grundsätzlich sind es
das sieht man aber ja ich glaube jetzt
ist genug gesagt dazu hinter lich ist in
der föderalismus barriere arbeit und
gibt es erkenntnisse daraus für den
nächsten krise die besten erkenntnisse
hat man hinterher und dann ist man der
beste der prognosen abgeben konnten
wir sind mitten drin und es stellen sich
jeden tag neue fragen und erkenntnisse
für hinterher die sich sie kennen das
mit den zetteln man schreibt sich sehr
viele auf ich habe eine datei bei mir wo
ich all diese themen mir notiere das ist
bei lebensmittelskandalen so dass bei
anderen punkten so und jetzt sind wir an
lösungen erstmal beschäftigt und nicht
daran dass wir mit den ländern jetzt
sagen was ich jetzt irgendwann ändern
muss wie hinderlich ist realismus
na ja ich würde es so pauschal jetzt gar
nicht sagen wir haben erlebt dass naja
ist ein gewissen abstimmungsbedarf schon
benötigt vor allen dingen irritationen
da sind wenn länder unterschiedlich
handeln also gesundheitlich kommen jetzt
noch mal dazu es geht ja häufig um
kommunale entscheidungen und da geht es
um die gesundheitsämter und
gesundheitsämter gehen zum teil sehr
unterschiedlich mit verdachtsfällen um
ob jetzt zum beispiel ein betrieb sofort
geschlossen wird oder ob der
verdachtsfall was man von ihm verlangt
jetzt 14 tage erstmal raus genommen zu
werden oder dass es einen test gibt dass
da gibt es sehr unterschiedliche
vorgehensweisen da ist es hilfreich und
ich nehme das so war dass die länder
bestrebt sind dass sie da stärker
miteinander sich abstimmen wollen ich
kann nur zu meinen agrarminister
kolleginnen und kollegen sagen
egal welcher partei dass wir wirklich
gut zusammen arbeiten dass wir gestern
abend unserer schaltkonferenz hatten
dass wir jetzt auch aus den ländern die
spezifischen fragestellungen zum
beispiel der länder die in grenzregionen
sind zugeliefert bekommen und gemeinsam
wirklich da gemeinsam monate auseinander
gehen
da handeln wollen und sag mal wenn wir
das alles überstanden haben schauen wir
uns an was vielleicht optimierbar ist
letzte folge auf ein sehr altes gebeten
hatte n tv frau klöckner wünscht sich
flexiblere lösungen damit saisonarbeiter
aus osteuropa doch noch kommen können
was haben sie da so sicher ist wie das
tor ja schwerlich dachte er kurz diesem
jahr an
was haben sie da über angebot für
flexible lösungen und kann da zum
beispiel auch eine ausnahmeregelung oder
einreise für zusammenarbeit
dabei sind zum beispiel der
passierschein hatte ich ja vorhin
erwähnt dass wir jetzt erstmal probleme
zusammentragen die sind also ich sage
jetzt mal wir haben kein defizit in der
problembeschreibung das ist uns allen
klar und sehr differenziert auch klar
auch aus allen ländern und jetzt geht es
darum dass man lösungen findet passgenau
findet und priorisiert das glaube ich
ist jetzt auch wichtig dass wir auch
priorisieren
um welche bereiche der
saisonarbeitskräfte ist auch geht
und insofern ich will es einfach nochmal
schlagwortartig sagen weil ich vorhin ja
schon glaube ich erwähnt hatte es geht
zum einen darum kriegen wir eine
flexibilisierung hin dass aus anderen
arbeitsbereichen wo die arbeit komplett
an niederlegt wo es keine aufträge gibt
es auch keine einkommen gibt aber das
wäre es dort erleichtern dass personen
die wollen und können dann in der
landwirtschaft starten können das hat
etwas damit zu tun mit
zuverdienstgrenzen mit regelungen
arbeitsrechtlichen regelungen die müssen
erklären
zweiter punkt ist die frage kann man zum
beispiel ich stelle es jetzt nur als
frage hin weil ich weil wir das erst
klären müssen bei der 70 tage regelung
wenn arbeiter hier im land sind saison
arbeiter die auch bleiben wollen
ob wir hier flexibler begrenzt
arbeiten können also eine regelung
finden ich komme zu einem dritten punkt
da ging es um passiere oder pendler
scheine zum beispiel auch das müssen wir
klären das sind viele europäische fragen
oder bilaterale fragen dann die frage ob
der reiseweg eine andere sein kann
stichwort per flugzeug wenn die
transitländer eher problematisch sind
das die arbeitskräfte nicht zu uns
kommen können also das sind so konkret
was wir besprochen haben flexible
mögliche flexible lösungen will nur
sagen das ganze ist ja an problemen
aufgekommen am wochenende also sehr
verschärft wir haben gestern intensiv
darüber gerät wir sind heute in erster
klärungen also nochmal ich will einfach
noch mal auch ein bisschen appellieren
daran dass bevor man eine lösung hat man
das problem fest um reisen muss und dann
auch seriös an lösungen arbeiten muss
und die gibt es nicht immer von jetzt
auf gleich per knopfdruck dann aber ich
hoffe dass das jetzt umrissen ist letzte
klärung noch von außen als wir eben
gesprochen haben über beschränkungen da
ging es um mengen abgaben beschränkte
menge abgaben aber die frage richtete
sich auch darauf dies offenbar nicht
richtig beantwortet worden ist es
sinnvoll personenzahl im leben zu
beschränken
das hatten sie ja hensel professor
hensel vorhin beantwortet hat er ja
angesprochen ich ganz normal noch mal
sagen das ist tatsächlich könnte ich
jetzt sagen ich bin nicht zuständig aber
es ist tatsächlich so dass das robert
koch institut im moment ja auch klar
gesagt hat also wir haben unsere regeln
wie wir miteinander umgehen
die zugangsbeschränkungen wenn sie dann
auf der seite der medizinischen
fragestellungen gegen hat er einfach nur
damit zu tun wie viele leute darin sind
und wie hoch die einstellungsmöglichkeit
eben ist und wir sind noch nicht so weit
und es gibt auch keine fachlichen
empfehlungen dass wir zu machen
und wenn das thema so sein wird ist das
eine politische entscheidung dann frau
ministerin aber interessanter den
zugeschalteten fragen ja ich hoffe auch
an die außen das hat geklappt so vielen
dank
nächsten mal alles gute